When working through this problem, here's some important points to note. One,
write down all of your work as you do it. Two, write down and label all the
values, every intermediate step. You're going to need the values throughout the
example. And throughout, round every answer to two decimal places. Even when
you're working through a problem, if we're doing these problems for real. In
other words, these are actual data from an actual research study. We wouldn't
round to two decimal places throughout, because that adds a rounding error. But
just for the sake of you understanding how to work these problems and interpret
them, two decimal places is fine. Here's the start of our problem. According to
the Gallup organization, US families reported spending an average of $151 per
week on food in 2012. Now, although, this data came from a sample, we're going
to pretend that this perfectly represents the whole population. So we're just
going to assume that this is mu. Make sure you write that down, mu equals 151.
Now, imagine that there's a food cooperative. We'll call them Food Now, and
they want to reduce their cost of food for their members. To do so, they
implement some cost-saving programs. This could include things like, buying
from local growers, and so on.